il y avait un mec qui avait un petit
gars de 10 ans qui venait de sauver la
vie de cette petite fille bro
je viens de sauver la vie de cette petite fille bruh
merci mon Dieu bruh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et il était comme b tu sais quoi  c'est ce que
je viens de voir et j'étais comme
quoi c'était comme un homme qui ressemblait à ce
signe de genou argenté qu'ils voient
sur le regard ambre qu'il a vu sur le
parapluie [Applaudissements]
la voiture juste là la petite fille est en
sécurité en ce moment
elle est en sécurité  en ce moment elle dit mon frère
merci mon Dieu tu sais ce que je dis
parce que j'ai une petite fille
tu sais ce que je veux dire